في سابقه تسجل منذ قرن فشل الجمهوريون في
اختيار رئيسا لمجلس النواب الامريكي خلال
عده جلسات رغم فوزهم في الانتخابات
النصفيه في نوفمبر الماضي
هو بحسب راي العلاقه الشخصيه السيئه بينهم
كارت في السابق والان هو فقط موعد الحساب
اثبتت حاله الفوضى التي يعيشها الحزب
الجمهوري واضعف شخصيه الرئيس بغض النظر عن
النتيجه التي سيتم التوصل اليها عكس
الواقع الذي فرضته المراه الحديديه نانسي
من جميع الاطراف وهذا سيكون خيارا صعبا
للغايه
مع غياب لاي منافس جاد لمكارسي عكس
اليومين الاولين لسيطره الحزب الجمهوري
على المجلس الصعوبات التي تواجه اغلبيتهم
متحده في مواجهه الرئيس جودا الامر الذي
سيتيح هامشا من المناورات الديمقراطيين
الذين يتوجسون من بدء منافسهم تحقيقات
تنال من الرئيس وافراد عائلته بانتظار
صفقات قد تسمح لهم بالحصول على ما فشلوا
بالحصول عليه في الانتخابات النصفيه
[تصفيق]
اللفت بكل ما يحصل حتى اللحظه تبقى مطالبه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بدعم ماكرتي
التي لم تلقى اي استجابه لدى نواب تجمع
الحريه الامر الذي يطرح المزيد من علامات
الاستفهام حول تاثير ترامب على الحزب
الجمهوري في هذه المرحله ريتا سليمان
العربيه واشنطن